listen listen to the sound know that
I've been here the whole time you just
came out oh thank you Dericks why do you
have a men's bathing suit well one of
them is yours you left it at when we
have that pool party and you're like I'm
gonna keep these here cuz I'm gonna come
over all the time and then we we move so
we don't have a pool anymore and I
didn't know which ones were yours you
remember which one unbelievably these
ones that look like 1980s biker shorts
there's like a slit on these look at
that I went to an American Apparel which
is an erotic bookstore they account to
out 90% of outdoor homeless masturbation
their ass it's a fact I want to wear
them and run on the beach like 80s
hassle thank you for bringing the mesh
oh these I have them
you feel sir they don't give away used
bathing suits on Fallon yeah that's one
thing we're doing way better than them
is giving away unwashed mail bathing
suits flung into the face of the
stranger and then passed like an
offering plate back three